(beatboxing)
- I'm Pops, the mentor.
- And I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
Nicole Paris, the apprentice.
(beatboxing)
- Beatboxing is just simply
making sounds with your mouth.
Making music with your mouth.
When beatboxing came to St.
Louis in the early ‘80s,
it was always about
emulating what the DJ did.
So I just thought of perfecting
my skill as I got older
and then, my wife, she
gets pregnant with Nicole.
So I would beatbox up against the belly
and Nicole would start
twisting and you would see
my wife's belly almost like (beatboxing).
She liked it, she thought
it was funny and cute.
And then, as Nicole got
bigger in the belly,
it wasn't cute no more.
- At the age of 13,
was my first talent show.
I just went home and I said,
"Pops, I just joined a talent show,
"you're going to
teach me how to beatbox."
He taught me how to hold a
mic, taught me how to breath,
taught me the basic beats.
I went to the talent show and did that.
They made me mad at the talent show,
they was clapping off-beat.
And they was like (slow clapping).
I then started to add my own
thing to what he thought me.
- One night, I came home from work
and as I'm walking in the door...
(beatboxing)
I heard her making all
these strange noises.
I had to tell her, like, “That's not beatboxing.
"Nah, don't do that, that's corny."
- I was like, (record screech) "what?"
- This is when I had to
realize and tell myself,
“Look, this is what she wants to do."
(beatboxing)
- Me and Pops, we
beatbox anywhere, all day.
- It don't even make a difference.
- No, it really don't.
We beatbox while cooking, barbershop, ...
- When we ready to
beatbox, it literally ...
- It happens.
- It doesn't matter.
If you go to her YouTube channel,
you will see us sitting down, beatboxing,
and to some folks, it can
look like a competition.
- We're not really battling, it's just ...
- It's just jam sessions,
just us having fun.
This is how I bond with
my child even though 160 million people will
be like, “Pops, you lost.”
"Pop, loser!"
I want her to be the best.
I want her to, to outdo me.
Not in outdo me, like, as in a
battle, but I want her to
just, just continue to grow
and add to beatboxing.
(soft music and chime)